ahora hay dos lados el lado del que
estoy yo que está el pasillo por dónde
está saliendo detrás mío se va a empezar
a ver gente que ya pudo ingresar y
despedirse de diego armando maradona
aquí es un poco más solemne aunque hay
algunos gritos algunos vivas de
despedida de despedida se escucha gritos
por ejemplo de diego es argentina y es
un punto interesante porque tiene que
ver con la fuerte identificación del
país con la figura de diego armando
maradona del otro lado entonces está la
gente esperando para ingresar el
ambiente es un poco más viva si se
quiere festivo como ha ocurrido desde el
día miércoles del día de su
fallecimiento hay mucha intensidad en
esta despedida y mucha celebración de la
vida de maradona de lo que representa
para en argentina y eso es lo que se
encuentra del otro lado donde se
escuchan cánticos vivas y la despedida
intensa que está ofreciéndole el pueblo
argentino diego armando maradona se
espera que los restos sean velados aquí
en la casa rosada hasta las cuatro de la
tarde argentina pero existe la
posibilidad de que tal vez que se
extienda dependiendo de la cantidad de
gente y el deseo de la familia que había
pedido que fuera una
despedida corta y todavía se están por
confirmar detalles concretos del funeral
y el entierro de diego maradona que ya
sabemos que será donde están los restos
de sus padres en un cementerio privado
en las afueras de buenos aires
natalio gracias por la información sin
duda un icono de argentina por supuesto